we're told that chloe takes a slice of
pizza out of the freezer and leaves it
on the counter to defrost
she models the relationship between the
temperature p of the pizza this seems
like it's going to be interesting the
temperature p of the pizza in degrees
celsius and time t since she took it out
of the freezer in minutes
as p is equal to
20 minus 25
times 0.8 to the t power so that's how
she's modeling
her
temperature of the pizza p
as a function of time
she wants to graph the relationship over
the first 25 minutes
so what we're going to do here is not so
much focus on the graph itself although
we will look at that i'm actually just
going to use a graphing calculator in
order to have access to the graph
but i want to look at the graph in the
context of what we are trying to model
and carefully think about what should be
the labels for the axes what parts of
the graph are interesting
so this right over here is this function
graphed on desmos you can see i typed it
in right over here p is equal to 20
minus 25 times 0.8 to the t power
exactly what we had down here
now remember this is modeling the
temperature of our pizza as a function
of time so to help us remember that
let's put in some labels for our axes so
to graph
settings
if i go down here our x-axis now our
x-axis is really the t-axis that's our
independent variable over here and what
is it measuring
well it says it right over here it's
measuring time t in minutes so we could
write it like this t
which is measured in minutes
and then what about our
y axis
well this is
really our p axis and that's measuring
degrees celsius so that's our p axis and
it's measuring
degrees
celsius
cs
all right so let's just look at what our
graph looks like so far
so there we have it we've put in our
axes and we have already typed this part
in so i can make it so i can focus on
the graph itself
now are we done is this all we need to
really think about well the next part to
think about is the domain and what part
of the y-axis what is the what part of
the range are we really interested in
well the first thing to realize is we're
modeling something as a function of time
and so we really shouldn't be having
negative time here and we want to think
about the relationship over the first 25
minutes
so
let's
let's go back here and when we look at
the the
range of x values that we care about and
really that we could think about the
part of the domain that we care about we
want to restrict to x being greater than
or equal to zero and obviously in this
situation x is really t and then we can
also think about it as less than 25 we
don't have to restrict the upper bound
but these are the first 25 minutes that
she cares about
so let's do it like that
and now let's look at our
graph
and the important things to appreciate
is that we have the axes
we can see them
and so at time t is equal to zero we see
that we actually have a negative
temperature in degrees celsius and that
makes sense it came out of the freezer
so it's below freezing and then we see
that the pizza is warming up as it gets
closer and closer to room temperature
which over here looks like it's pretty
close to 20 degrees celsius and so now
it looks like we have been able to graph
what chloe is trying to look at it looks
like we have modeled it well we have
labeled it accordingly and we have set
the ranges of x values and the ranges of
y values that we'd want to look at the y
values we just want to make sure that
over the the range of x values it's
really a subset of the domain not to
confuse the term range too much the
subset of the domain of the x values
that we care about that we can see the
corresponding y values and we very
clearly can see them and we're
essentially done
we've thought about how to best look at
the graph of this model